ALL OF THE RELEVANT FACTORS, AND
DO JUSTICE INDIVIDUALLY IN EACH
CASE.
>> LET'S KEEP TALKING ABOUT
THERE CASE.
YOU ALSO SAID TO THIS INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS AN ADULT, TRIED AS AN
ADULT.
18 YEARS OLD.
YOU ALSO SAID, BESIDES SAYING
YOU THOUGHT HIS VICTIMS WERE HIS
PEERS.
YOU SAID THERE'S NO REASON TO
THINK YOU ARE A PEDOPHILE.
AND THEN YOU WENT ON TO SAY,
THAT IS ANOTHER REASON WHY YOU
WEREN'T -- YOU WERE ONLY GOING
TO GIVE HIM THREE MONTHS.
BECAUSE HE WAS NOT A PEDOPHILE.
AND THEN YOU SAID, AND THIS IS
SOMETHING I REALLY NEED YOUR
HELP UNDERSTANDING.
THEN YOU APOLOGIZED TO HIM.
AND I HAVE TO TELL YOU, I CAN'T
QUITE FIGURE THIS OUT.
YOU SAID TO HIM, THIS IS A TRULY
DIFFICULT SITUATION.
I APPRECIATE THAT YOUR FAMILY IS
IN THE AUDIENCE.
I FEEL SO SORRY FOR THEM AND FOR
YOU AND FOR THE ANGUISH THIS HAS
CAUSED ALL OF YOU.
I FEEL TERRIBLE ABOUT THE
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES OF THIS
CONVICTION.
AND THEN YOU GO ON TO SAY, SEX
OFFENDERS ARE TRULY SHUNNED IN
OUR SOCIETY.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT, JUDGE,
IS HE THE VICTIM HERE?
OR THE VICTIMS ARE THE VICTIMS?
YOU'RE SAYING, YOU'RE
APOLOGIZING TO HIM.
YOU'RE SAYING, YOU'RE SORRY FOR
THE ANGUISH THIS HAS CAUSED HIM.
THERE WAS A VICTIM IMPACT IN
THIS CASE.
IT DIDN'T GET READ INTO THE
RECORD BUT IT WAS THERE.
I DESCRIBED THE VIDEOS THAT WE
HAVE.
YOU SAY EARLIER IN THE CASE, YOU
TALK ABOUT HOW HEINOUS THESE
CRIME ARE.
AND YOU DESCRIBED HOW HEINOUS IT
IS, TO YOUR CREDIT.
AND YET HERE YOU ARE GIVING HIM
THREE MONTHS AND APOLOGIZING TO
HIM AND SAYING YOU FEEL SORRY
FOR THE ANGUISH IT CAUSED HIM
AND SAYING YOU THINK SEX
OFFENDERS ARE TRULY SHUNLED IN
OUR SOCIETY.
SO TALK ABOUT THAT.
HELP ME UNDERSTAND.
IS HE A VICTIM?
IS THAT WHAT YOU MEN?
>> SENATOR, I AGAIN DON'T HAVE
THE ENTIRE RECORD.
I REMEMBER IN THAT PARTICULAR
CASE, I CONSIDERED IT TO BE
UNUSUAL.
IN PART FOR THE REASONS THAT I
DESCRIBED.
I REMEMBER.
IN CASE THAT DEFENSE COUNSEL WAS
ARGUING FOR PROBATION.
IN PART, BECAUSE HE ARGUED THAT
HERE WE HAD A VERY YOUNG MAN,
JUST GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
HE PRESENTED ALL OF HIS DIPLOMAS
AND CERTIFICATES AND THE THINGS
THAT HE HAD DONE, AND ARGUED
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT I WAS
SEEING IN THE RECORD, THAT THIS
PARTICULAR DEFENDANT HAD GOTTEN
INTO THIS IN A WAY THAT WAS,
INCONSISTENT WHAT I SAW.
PART OF WHAT A JUDGE IS DOING AS
REQUIRED BY CONGRESS, IS
THINKING ABOUT THIS CASE,
THINKING ABOUT UNWARRANTED
SENTENCING DISPARITIES.
THAT'S IN THE STATUTE.
OTHER CASES, OTHER
DETERMINATIONS THAT A JUDGE MAY
HAVE MADE ABOUT THIS.
I DON'T REMEMBER IN DETAIL THIS
PARTICULAR CASE BUT I DO RECALL
IT BEING UNUSUAL.
AND SO MAY ONLY POINT TO YOU IS
THAT JUDGES ARE DOING THE WORK
OF ASSESSING IN EACH CASE A
NUMBER OF FACTORS THAT ARE SET
FORWARD BY CONGRESS.
ALL AGAINST THE BACK DROP OF
HEINOUS CRIMINAL BEHAVIOR.
BUT THE GUIDELINES ARE NO LONGER
MANDATORY.
CONGRESS HAS NOT CORRECTED, AS
YOU WOULD SAY, THE SUPREME
COURT'S DETERMINATION OF THAT.
JUSTICE SCALIA'S DECISION THAT
THE GUIDELINES ARE NOT
MANDATORY.
CONGRESS HAS NOT SAID THAT.
AND CONGRESS HAS GIVEN JUDGES
FACTORS TO CONSIDER.
THIS IN MY VIEW WAS AN UNUSUAL
CASE THAT HAD A NUMBER OF
FACTORS THAT THE DEFENDANT WAS
POINTING OUT.
THAT THE GOVERNMENT WAS POINTING
OUT.
THE PROBATION OFFICE WAS
POINTING OUT.
AND I SENT THIS 18-YEAR-OLD TO
THREE MONTHS IN FEDERAL PRISON
UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES THAT WERE
PRESENTED IN THIS CASE BECAUSE I
WANTED HIM TO UNDERSTAND THAT
WHAT HE HAD DONE WAS HARMFUL.
THAT WHAT HE HAD DONE WAS
UNLAWFUL.
THAT WHAT HE HAD DONE VIOLATED
THE LAW AND NEEDED TO BE
PUNISHED.
NOT ONLY BY PRISON BUT
ANALYSIS, BUT THESE ARE THINGS
THEY SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME
ON TODAY.
>> WHICH THEY SHOULD.
YOU SHOULD ALWAYS QUESTION A
NOMINEE'S RECORD, BUT MUCH OF
THAT DISCUSSION WAS MISLEADING
BECAUSE IT SORT OF MISSTATED
WHAT THE POINT OF FEDERAL
SENTENCING GUIDELINES ARE.
THEY EXIST AS SORT OF BOUNDARIES
FOR JUDGES TO FOLLOW.
AND SHE DID.
IN MOST OF HER CASES, WELL IN
LINE WITH HOW JUDGES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY SENTENCE.
AND FRANKLY, IF SENATOR HAWLEY
OR ANY OTHER SENATOR WISHED TO
PUT IN PLACE A MINIMUM SENTENCE,
GRAB 59 OF YOUR COLLEAGUES, PASS
A LAW, BUT DON'T PIN THAT ON A
NOMINEE WHOSE BEHAVIOR WITH
RESPECT TO SENTENCING HAS BEEN
PERFECTLY IN LINE WITH JUDGES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
MORE IMPORTANTLY, AND CORY
BOOKER TOUCHED ON THIS AT THE
END AS WELL.
SHE IS SUPPORTED BY POLICE
ORGANIZATIONS AND FRATERNAL
ORDER OF POLIC